we have finally watched the movie and it
is
damn good and in this video we shall do
a bit of a review
without spoilers and tell you guys how
we as mind you
feel about this epic movie and also what
are the good and bad traits of it
of course there will be no reveal
anything of that sword no spoilers but
this would be something like it just on
the action
that many of you will see in the coming
days of course in the united states it
will be out on the 31st of march
and a day later in the united kingdom
germany canada and other countries i
think will be on the 25th of march
or the 24th that is today i don't know
anyway
let's get down with the sickness the
movie has a very upbeat thing about it
it isn't as dark as the other two
godzilla movies
quite the opposite of godzilla 2014 in
fact godzilla and kong are gonna face
each other and
fight till one of them gives out that's
for sure but there are a series of
battles and not just
one in fact there are two or three
rounds just with each other
and there are also other monster fights
along the way and after that
we will get to see the different kaiju
designs that are quite unique
and original to the most verse and not
really taken from toho
these kaiju or titans are of a different
size
different sizes but with some being
small and already seen in skull island
while others are new to the hollow earth
overall i would say that this movie is
worth the money
and it kind of leaves sort of a
cliffhanger as to a future potential
sequel that would follow suit
if it goes well in the theaters and the
streaming services
what do i think about the cast members
the humans in the show
well they actually were sort of
in the words of gordon ramsay this [ __ ]
is bland
the storyline took a massive jump from
one plot point to another and
forcing them to connect without a smooth
flow but the creatures did steal the
show
and save the film come to think about it
there was more
emphasis on one titan over another in
the story arc
with one being well established and more
cemented in the monster verse already
and the other one that needed a proper
revelation of his origins
in the movies not the comics regarding
the war bats
this creature isn't as sweet as you saw
in the trailer scenes
it does pack quite a punch and gives kom
a run for his money
per se yes there were other creatures in
the whole earth and there are scenes of
them living and going about in their
ecosystem
it would have been a great thing if
there was sort of a documentary type of
film
you know like from national geographic
or discovery channel or the animal
planet
kind of thing in the hollow earth in the
monster verse narrated by
either morgan freeman or that bad guy
from v for vendetta
it would have been good it would be
awesome to see them live their lives and
fight for survival
in this alien world that is also our own
well the origins of kong would be
vaguely seen and just as in the trailer
we will get to see the throne room of
the kongs
there will be many gasping mounts in
this part of the movie
when team kong and the big ape arrive in
that place and whatever happens
afterwards
so yes let's just go back to godzilla
otherwise i would just might might
reveal some spoilers
okay let's go back to godzilla we would
slowly and steadily see his reasons for
attacking cities across the world and
even the carrier battle group of
warships
there is a method to his madness and
although it might be not apparent
at first slowly and steadily the story
arc will pan out and dots would be
connected but in my own opinion i think
there should have been more emphasis on
godzilla
and less on these pesky homo sapiens
regarding the final battle in hong kong
well this one will feature out the two
titles giving everything they got on
each other
with the bell being one of the
lengthiest monster battles in history
well pacific rim and touhou might have
given longer battle scenes but in this
movie
the fights are well connected blow for
blow and there would be no lull in
between
no calm before the storm it would be a
long ass donator that will take down
buildings and cars and leave the city of
hong kong
in smothering ruins and yes as per the
rumors and trailer scenes
mechagodzilla will make his debut
appearance this maker will not be the
same as the earlier incarnations
this one will have an edge in melee
battle hand-to-hand combat
and very powerful weapons as well as a
beam attack maybe